as mentioned in the previous exercise
there are many methods that you can use
to identify the heat from any of the RNA
I library screening that includes for
example using the Cisco or using the Raz
analysis or using the rigor analysis in
this exercise we are going to show you
how you can actually use the RSA
analysis to actually identify the hits
from the RNA I library screen now before
we go into the RSA analysis you should
have all the C score calculated based on
the shRNA C and we will use this C score
as an input for the RSA analysis now
before we move forward what I'm going to
do is okay I'm going to create a new
create a new input file in Excel
basically we just create a new sheet and
then you are going to label three
columns with the hater gene ID
well ID and also for the score
okay so now we switch back to our C
score excel sheet here basically so the
gene ID is basically a gene symbol that
we have you can actually copy this over
here at the gene ID and then the well ID
would be the TRC number so or the
reference or the reference here and we
will copy this again and then we will
paste it and well ID and then after that
you would then copy the score in this
case here which is basically the z score
here just grow it now and then copy the
z score all the way from the bottom so
okay now you will see that okay some of
the z score have actually a blank value
for RSA to work you will need to remove
those blank cell basically I'm going to
select the blank cell and then I'm going
to delete all these rows okay okay so
now you should have all the data rate
the next thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to save this okay as input file
but in the CSV format okay so research
this will be and dry
okay and I'm going to save this under
input okay dot CSV okay next what I'm
going to do is basically launch the RSA
program now the RSA by itself by default
it is already set in a way to actually
identify the genes that were knocked out
and actually induced tumor cell death so
in that way basically it is set to
identify the the genes that are depleted
or the shrna that's depleted in any of
the SH or any library screen so in our
case we actually don't have to change
anything you can actually use back the
same setting as it is if you want to
understand more about what is this lower
boundary and the upper boundary setting
you can actually do it on the help file
to understand more about the algorithm
so anyway so for this exercise so what
we are going to do is we are going to
input the file that we have created just
now so this is in the CSV format and
then the output file okay we'll
basically save on you know in the same
folder as well before you press a Run
button it's always remember that you
actually have to close the input file
first or else and it will come up with
an error message so now that input CSV
file is already closed so you just need
to press the Run button here okay
then once you finish then a pop-up
window will come up here no ok so now if
we go into the output files so we can
actually so see what are the data that
is being calculated so basically when
you open the output file what you can
see is that what the gene ID is what we
input and then the well IDs also what we
input the score this is actually the z
score that we input as well now the most
important thing that with column that we
want to pay attention to is actually
this one here which is the log p value
as you can see here in this data search
basically for C cat 5 there are about 20
shrna tada
the same gene and when you consolidate
and take into account all the different
shrna so the probability or the p-value
okay for decaf five is appear to be very
very significant which is basically at
the log P of minus thirteen so if you
want to know the p-value you can easily
calculate it
it's basically ten power of the value so
it is actually six point nine to my six
point nine two times ten power of minus
fourteen the p-value is highly
significant so now there are also other
data other results that you might be
interested for example number of heat
well so they are about seventeen heat
well out of twenty so again well you can
read up more about the activity or or
the information on rs8 and you will
comprehend much about all these
additional data as well but for this
exercise what we are going to do is we
are going to focus exclusively or more
into the log p value so you will see
that okay for each particular gene
there's only log p value so this is
common because as I mentioned it before
the log p value basically reflect the p
value of the particular gene when they
take consolidate and take into account
of all the SH okay the next thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to put it into
the master sheet that that we have
created since the beginning of this
exercise basically in here I have one
column which is basically all the genes
in the data set so altogether three
thousand four hundred of them and of
course I have all these cell lines as
included in the study so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to copy the gene
ID and also the log p value into this
this data sheet here now and the next
thing what I'm going to do is I'm going
to remove the duplicate okay so that
each gene would then have okay one
unique log p value so the next thing to
come
into this table basically I'm just going
to use we lock up okay so the lookup
value would be this and then the table
array would be here and then return off
the column number two here and then
force so remember that we looked up
formula again you can look at the
previous video how it is being created
it is a very useful formula in Excel
that you can use it to match the genes
basically ordered in the dataset
what you need to do is then you just
copy and paste here just to double check
basically the CK 5 is minus 13 so I'm
going to search for C CAP 5 see whether
okay okay fine it okay I think that's
fine we take a while to compile
okay we can find C cat5 for example okay
you can see that is minus 13 so and see
our CR cor o to P is minus 0.06 we can
see minus 0.66 okay
so that's all for the RSA basically you
just need to do for the rest of the cell
lines and then you can then get the p
value for each of the genes whether they
are significant or not thank you